ya hemos visto esta reacción es la
descomposición del dióxido de nitrógeno
en óxido nítrico y oxígeno y ya hemos
probado que es una reacción de segundo
orden de hecho ya está encontramos la
constante de velocidad de la reacción a
300 grados entonces pues vamos a
resolver el inciso a en donde tenemos
una concentración inicial de dióxido de
nitrógeno de 0.008 molar y queremos
saber cuál es la concentración del
dióxido de nitrógeno 20 minutos después
y pues como ya sabemos que es una
reacción de segundo orden entonces pues
podemos utilizar la ley de la velocidad
integrada para reacciones de segundo
orden ok que la calculamos hace algunos
vídeos y dice que uno entre la
concentración del reactivo a un tiempo t
menos uno entre la concentración del
reactivo al inicio de la reacción es
igual a la
constante de velocidad de la reacción
que la tenemos por aquí por el tiempo
que nos interesa aunque haya este mismo
tiempo ahora ya que vamos a utilizar
esta ley de la velocidad integrada pues
hay que pensar qué cosas podemos
sustituir y por supuesto vamos a
necesitar más espacio y haber aquí el
reactivo que nos interesa es el dióxido
de nitrógeno y la concentración inicial
del dióxido de nitrógeno en el inciso a
es de 0.00 8 molar entonces lo que
tenemos es 1 entre la concentración del
dióxido de nitrógeno menos 1 entre la
concentración inicial del dióxido de
nitrógeno que es 0.008 y esto es igual a
la constante de velocidad de la reacción
que la tenemos por aquí
es 0.54 por uno entre molares por
segundo y todo esto lo tenemos que
multiplicar por el tiempo que son 20
minutos pero la velocidad de la reacción
está en segundos y el tiempo nos lo
están dando en minutos por lo cual
tenemos que convertirlo a segundos
aunque ahí tenemos 20 minutos y hay 60
segundos en cada minuto
y entonces simplemente multiplicamos
esto de aquí minutos se cancelan con
minutos y nos quedan 20 por 60 segundos
aunque hay pero 20 por 60 es 1200 así es
que por aquí tenemos que multiplicar por
mil 200 segundos y por supuesto aquí
tenemos la concentración del dióxido de
nitrógeno en el tiempo te iguala 20
minutos pero pues para no poner aquí 20
minutos o 1200 segundos o algo que nos
estorbe mucho lo voy a dejar así nada
más bueno entonces vamos a hacer todas
estas cuentas en la calculadora ponemos
por aquí punto 54 por 1200 y nos da 648
creyó entonces tenemos 600 48 y en
cuanto a las unidades observa que este
uno entre segundos se cancela con estos
segundos y nos queda simplemente uno
sobre molares y bueno por aquí del lado
izquierdo tenemos que sacar la
calculadora para ver
es uno sobre punto 008 entonces ponemos
uno en 3.008 y esos son 125
125 con un signo de menos y uno entre la
concentración del dióxido de nitrógeno
al tiempo que igual a 20 minutos y pues
queremos encontrar esta concentración de
aquí entonces sumamos 648 más 125 y eso
pues son 773 y nos queda de este lado
simplemente 1 sobre la concentración del
dióxido de nitrógeno así es que para
encontrar la concentración del dióxido
de nitrógeno dióxido de nitrógeno
simplemente tenemos que tomar 1 / 773
aunque hay ponemos uno entre 773 y eso
es punto 0 013 aproximadamente
ok esto es igual a 0.00 13 molar
entonces si empiezas con una
concentración inicial de 0.008 molar
después de 20 minutos tienes una
concentración de 0.00 13 molar bueno
ahora vamos con el inciso b
si la concentración inicial del dióxido
de nitrógeno es 0.008 molar cuál es la
vida media en el vídeo pasado obtuvimos
una fórmula para encontrar la vida media
de reacciones de segundo orden y lo que
encontramos es que la vida media es
igual a 1 entre la constante de
velocidad de la reacción por la
concentración inicial del reactivo que
en este inciso para esta reacción esto
es igual a 1 entre la constante de
velocidad de la reacción que es 0.54
0.54 y las unidades son 1 entre molares
por segundo por la concentración inicial
del dióxido de nitrógeno que en este
inciso es 0.008 molar entonces ponemos
por aquí
0.00 800 molar
entonces pues saquemos la calculadora y
ponemos 0.54 por punto 0 08 y eso nos da
punto 0 0 432 y luego queremos poner 1
entre nuestra respuesta y eso es 231
aunque esa es nuestra vida media y en
notación científica eso sería 2.3 por 10
al cuadrado segundos entonces la vida
media de un medio es igual a 2.3 por 10
al cuadrado segundos también podemos
decir aproximadamente 230 segundos
entonces si empezamos con una
concentración de 0.008 molar 0.008 molar
esperamos aproximadamente doscientos
treinta segundos obtenemos la mitad de
la concentración ósea 0.004 molar así es
que tenemos la mitad de la concentración
después de una vida media bueno vamos
con el siguiente inciso ahora comparemos
lo que obtuvimos en el inciso b con lo
que vamos a obtener en el inciso c ok
porque en este inciso c la concentración
inicial del dióxido de nitrógeno ahora
es de 0.00 4 molar y bueno pues también
queremos saber cuál es la vida media
empezando con esta concentración inicial
y los cálculos son exactamente los
mismos pero ahora tenemos esta
concentración inicial en lugar de esta
otra aunque entonces la vida media es
igual a 1 entre la constante de
velocidad de la reacción
por la concentración inicial del
reactivo porque entonces tenemos uno
entre la constante de velocidad sigue
siendo 0.54 y las unidades son 1 entre
molares por segundo pero ahora tenemos
que multiplicarlo por 0.004 molar
y bueno pues queremos encontrar esta
vida media entonces vamos a sacar la
calculadora ponemos punto 54 x 0.004 y
nos da esto de aquí pero lo que queremos
es 1 entre esa multiplicación que nos da
463 que esta es nuestra vida media 463
que en notación científica es 4.6 por 10
al cuadrado así es que la vida media es
igual a 4.6 por 10 al cuadrado segundos
y la vida media está en segundos y creo
que eso es algo que se me olvidó
enfatizar en el inciso pasado si nos
fijamos en las unidades aquí molares se
cancela con molares y nos queda 1 entre
1 entre segundos pero pues esto es
simplemente segundos ok la vida media se
mide en segundos y pasa exactamente lo
mismo en este inciso aunque hay molares
se cancelan con molares y nos queda 1
entre 1 en 3 segundos que es igual a
segundos
ok y otra cosa importante es que podemos
observar aquí que esta vida media es el
doble de esta otra vida media que hay si
empezamos con una concentración de 0.004
molar 0.004 molar y esperamos
aproximadamente 460 segundos
la concentración baja a 0.00 2
y la concentración disminuye a la mitad
después de esta vida media pero recuerda
para reacciones de segundo orden la vida
media no es constante depende de la
concentración inicial y bueno ya
hablamos de esto en el vídeo pasado pero
como podemos observar aquí la vida media
depende de la concentración inicial y si
por ejemplo tenemos dos concentraciones
iniciales distintas y una de estas
concentraciones es de la mitad que la
otra concentración la vida media de esa
concentración dura el doble de tiempo
que la vida media de la otra
concentración